[Musik]
dieser haufen bleibt am ende des tages
übrig aus den resten dieser gerichte ist
er entstanden eine idee von david suzuki
und jasmin martin
das paar hat in berlin das frühjahr
eröffnet deutschlands erste zero waste
restaurant jedes restaurant am
allgemeinen sollte nachhaltiger
produzieren und ob es sich jetzt auf die
fahne schreibt oder nicht aber es
sollten immer die betreiber haben eine
große verantwortung ihren gästen
gegenüber aber auch der umwelt weil das
tagesbedarf viel produziert und so viel
produziert wird fällt auch viel mit
möglichst müll frei und vegan leben
jasmin martin und david suzuki auch
privat schon seit jahren in ihr zero
waste restaurant kommen die produkte
plastik verpackt von biobauern aus der
region
alle gerichte sind vegan heute auf der
speisekarte
geröstete pilze mit knollensellerie an
kartoffel terrine und hausgemachtes
sauerteig fladenbrot mit dem c't
wollen niemanden wie genießen oder wie
alle zu zero race dann machen oder
wollen einfach mit dem essen am ende des
tages auf dem tisch punkten und
undogmatisch damit irgendwie aber ganz
klar immer noch pragmatisch bleiben wir
wollen was machen wir wollen nicht viel
reden die machen das konzept ist keine
berliner erfindung schon 2014 eröffnete
das silo als erstes zero waste
restaurant englert der norwegische koch
half dann kluften war dort zu chef bevor
er die küche im frühjahr übernahm seine
erfahrungen hat er mit nach berlin
gebracht
[Musik]
wer fermentieren unser ganzes saisonales
gemüse in salzwasser durch die
fermentierung bekommt das gemüse auf
einen viel interessanteren geschmack und
wir können die flüssigkeit anstelle von
essig und öl für die herstellung von
soßen oder dressings verwenden sie ist
eigentlich in jedem gericht enthalten
nachhaltigkeit und umweltbewusstsein
finden sich auch in der einrichtung
wieder so gibt es nur stoffservietten
die möbel sind secondhand verpackungen
werden durch glasbehälter ersetzt und
die lampen sind ost pilz fasern
das konzept ist bis ins kleinste detail
durchdacht doch wissen die gäste das
auch zu schätzen
ich finde das konzept interessant ich
habe zu hause auf dem buch was ich lese
dazu aber es freut sich der hauptgrund
dass ich herkomme grundsätzlich will ich
erstmal vom essen angezogen worden
es regt mich auf
dass wir sehr viel action und es sehr
schwierig wenig wegzuschmeißen und es
ist noch schwieriger gar nichts
wegzuschmeißen
da sind die jungs was sie erwarten recht
teuer und was passiert mit gemüse
abfällen und essensresten die übrig
bleiben
dafür ist dann gar sie zuständig die
hauseigene kompostieren maschine bei
temperaturen zwischen 60 bis 120 grad
celsius lebt und arbeitet hier ein
spezieller bakterien zu
[Musik]
und damit schließt sich der kreislauf
ganz natürlich